alright another episode of bitching
right here live at the All Things comedy
studio brought to you by my great
sponsor earthquaker devices check them
out if you play guitar bass drums
whatever you play music you need some
foot pedals some stompboxes some rock
and roll machines hit him up from Akron
Ohio handmade pedals up earthquaker
devices com check them out on Twitter
and Instagram what's happening Spicer
good to be back man we I'm you know we
bonded in Phoenix and you you went away
with some other young love to Las Vegas
I heard you got married I was San
Francisco also got married wow it's been
a long time welcome back yeah thank you
dude uh that's one of the things
Jeremiah he got lucky someone fell out a
host spot and he grabbed it yeah and um
you know thank god man Vegas for seven
days I it's really it's almost like a
test if you go alone you don't come back
oh it is [ __ ] brutal if you don't
gamble or or your bachelorette party or
anything like that you're in hell it's a
lonely it's a really fun place that
quickly becomes lonely if you're not
there just to yeah party for a weekend
like a for your like wolf the cigarettes
cigarettes alone look at this I see it
some house keys oh I got a [ __ ] place
to live man let's pop that there it is
ah done ah are you moved in or you know
I'm not moved in I just went it's so
funny today I opened it up and it's got
70s carpet in there we're waiting on a
call right now from bill burr which is
going to be great he has a brand new
show coming out December eighteenth on
Netflix it's an animated series called f
is for family and he just told me it got
an incredible review in the variety and
you haven't watched the trailer for it
stop listening to Dean and I babble and
go [ __ ] watch the trailer for it
right now oh it's incredible I'm gonna
love it because i love the air it's in
its its 70s and if you [ __ ] around you
your dad or mom would slap you know jail
now that is just growing
I wonder what the nostalgia will be for
this era for like my kids will they look
back and go yeah man I miss growing up
oh here he is let's grab the call yo
bill you there yeah now what's up there
is bill burr guys the great bill burr
we're just talking about your show right
now f is for family so pretty fired up
to see this it comes out on December
eighteenth right yes it does you can
watch all six episodes that took us four
years to do for years between between
initially pitching the idea to Wild West
and swans company finding a showrunner
coming up with the whole concept selling
it then you know though everything else
it's taken four years and you guys can
devour it in about two hours and 45
minutes okay now we've been watching the
trailers and it's I grew up in the 70s
and and I relate to it right away it's
definitely back before the pre PC era
and you know there's a great scene where
you're like grab me a beer there when
you're you were driving with your son in
the car that shit's real from the 70s
right I think it's still real i think a
lot of that real people just they just
focus on like the one person in the
crowd that got offended you know what i
mean in the other you know 300 people
that went to the show had a good time so
I think there's a you know I think
there's a sort of I don't know /
reporting on one spot to you I think
people are mature enough and adult
enough to realize they're watching your
cartoon and that 20 years of parenting
won't go out the window with one joke so
I think I think I'll be fine you can you
can really get away with stuff with
animation right because they just think
like oh it's just a cartoon right you
can get away with anything if the people
you're in business with uh don't treat
five complaints like they're five
billion complaints like I'm trying to
honestly think the last time I was
offended I've been shocked some of the
stuff that you know uh that guy that do
yet that Donald Trump
who yelled at the the Mexican guy who
was actually a citizen of the country
yes some white dude his fifties goes get
out of my country that surprised me I
was like really some guy in his 50 still
things done things like that why
shouldn't say but I wasn't offended I
was like well you know I've run into
racist on the road so I mean I wasn't
like I guess not offended the wrong word
i guess i was just may be depressed to
see something like that but the fact
that people will like go after comics
and you know with more gusto than they
will like stuff like that or like
bankers stealing from everybody in the
planet it's just you know I think we're
just easy target its clickbait nobody
really gets hurt and then a comic
apologizes and then it's over it's silly
really it's true right I it's amazing i
was just in vegas all week doing comedy
and it was rodeo we night oh yeah i
wasn't bragging i'm about to [ __ ]
show you I was one step I was cruise
ship on land Dean hugs the shows he
already did that go to ya anyway my
point is it was rodeo week so I was
doing a bit where I was like how do we
feel about Obama and I couldn't believe
the [ __ ] people would say out loud in
the audience you know and and then
they're worried about what I'm saying
you know what I mean like these guys
would yeah you know why me you know well
you get a bunch of drunk Cowboys you
can't do you think of our black
president what do you think going to
happen I because what I mean haven't
said that if somebody were to criticize
his presidency just with him as the
president I were I wouldn't have a
problem with that it's when you go to
that next level yeah yeah it gets that
song it starts you know you start
looking around for the nearest exit to
get out yep yeah now let me ask you
about the animation a little bit because
I'm a huge fan of animated stuff and I
think one of the best parts about that
Kurt Cobain montage of heck film was the
animation it was incredible now how did
you pick the style did you have a style
the look that you wanted because you
know we have like Simpson style then we
have like the what's the big one on
click Rick and Marty are so yeah salga
so which would stud you have a razor
yeah watch them all dude I love all axe
cop is a big big fan of axe cop all that
adult swim stuff and I think so South
Park's done the best social commentary
they just kind of done everything the
best as far as I'm concerned for like
the last almost 20 years I mean there
and I think people take them for granted
I think they're amazing but as far as
coming up with the staff reference or
family uh you know before we went into
it we knew what we wanted as far as this
we had a mission statement no lava lamp
I think it like every show about every
TV show or movie about the 70s it makes
it look like everybody at a lava lamp
and they drove a pacer or at a Hornet
you know what i mean by your son right
you're so right doesn't like they fry
Carl and that's not how it was like the
70s that I remember was you know there
was a bunch of cars from the 60s first
of all because most people drive a car
that's five six seven eight years old
few cars left over from the 50s and then
maybe your neighbors had some newer cars
it's sort of the early seventies uh you
know Serpico era of the 70s that we kind
of go Rust Belt kind of look as what we
were gone for so no pet rocks or mood
rings yeah no I remember I vividly
remember when the Pacer came out the
first time me and my mom we were riding
around and I don't know if we had a
Chevy Chevette at that point where we
still driving the buick but I remember
we saw that car and we were both
laughing going that is the ugliest thing
I knew it would hardly and I was like
seven or eight years old when it came
out but they make it seem like everybody
was just like know these things are cool
they those things were weird when they
came out they were weird ten years later
and they're still weird well the way
they do it in the movies is they make it
seem like people all made a sweet ride
like so sister go yeah yeah yeah that's
the hips
view of like the 70s where people were
completely unaware of stuff like that
yeah yeah now let's talk about the cast
so we got Laura Dern plays your wife
right yep Laura Dern plays my wife Susan
and then as far as the kids go Justin
Long place my son Kevin Kaylee Reinhardt
does the voice a little bill and Debbie
Derryberry who if you've watched any
pics our movie you've probably heard her
a million times does the voice of
Maureen the daughter and then filling
out the cast I mean we just got it Kevin
we got Kevin Michael Richardson mo
collins some mad tv Kevin Farley David
Kenner Gary Cole well Henry epic radio
fan I was vixon show uh Trevor Duvall
and even Joe [ __ ] Wow two blonde joke
I've got in there and did he did a great
job doing a voice in uh but it was you
know things really got going once once
we brought Mike price on from the
simpsons in the hole you know he's beast
but he's been over there forever and be
you know i have to be honest with you
like the planets really lined up like
Vince's company Wild West like I've
never been in business with people like
that they just know what they're doing
they know how to put together a team and
they know how to get something on air
and being in business with them and then
getting with Mike Price and then we got
it at Netflix denote the network notes i
got from from netflix was push it
further haha no [ __ ] they are not due to
spin a dream I mean I ton of work I'm
not gonna lie to you yeah and I've been
a bit of a baby a couple times towards
the end of the day getting all grumpy
you know I'm spoiled as a comic like JJ
benefit outweighs its really been a
dream situation and uh you know we had a
incredible writers room tom gianas Dave
Richardson uh we would just I know I'm
but I was never forget somebody we we
have we had it it was just we have we
just laughed our asses off I that's all
I remember was just writing to think
laughing every day get big lad
easy pious as it is but I definitely
have a whole new found respect for
writers in a writers room because you
know just from day one you know which
each script somebody has to go home and
get that big rock moving and start
pushing it up the hill and it's not so
you do the second or third rewrite that
you feel like the rocks rolling down the
hill and not going up and back you know
I had to I had to you know thank God I
had all those other people to prop me up
to help those stories get told now are
the stories from your childhood growing
up you just rip them to them and then
they start writing a story around it um
it's from everybody's childhood so like
when we when we put together the writers
room we just sort of ask people about
their childhood and if they had he told
you know if there's like you know my mom
always had an apple pie sitting on the
windowsill were like well that's great
see you later if they were just like
yeah my probably used to throw me down
the stairs every time I his team lost or
something for whatever we like this
stuff like that in you know there's so
many stories that people have and what
I'm hoping is when people watch this
show when we get a fan page I'm sure
people will start sharing story yeah
yeah that we could we can animate and
throw into the world if it fits I mean
even my manager told me a story they
should take road trips and he used to
always get carsick when he was a little
kid his dad didn't want to stop because
he didn't want to lose any time yeah so
when he would go to get sick his mother
would roll down the window and hold them
outside the car if you would be Cupid as
they would haha which is funny enough in
live in a live action but if you animate
that I mean just yeah once you can
you're actually what I like about this
show is you're like taking true stories
and then you add the whole element of
animation where you can really go over
the top at some points but you know just
like most of the stuff i try to do i
tried we tried to keep it grounded in
reality and have it be more like
character-driven jokes rather than set
up or punch but we got it we still have
a couple of silly jokes in there that i
love you got you got to get the scene in
there with the babysitter that spanks
you with a Hot Wheel track
that's hey that's some real [ __ ] okay oh
that's actually uh that's it night you
know that's something that's actually
hard you just saw the whole episode
that's a good be story [ __ ] psycho
babysitter mrs. Stevens just write that
one up um there you go all right I know
you got to get going but so one last
question now now when you were in the
video but was that weird to get used to
because I've seen when people do it like
the Simpsons and stuff it's so weird to
watch him in there and they're doing
their voices and everything was that
kind of cool and a strange new new thing
for you yeah so we both two or three I
think maybe like about three sessions
for me to get a hundred percent
comfortable and then I was able to to
just feel as comfortable as I am in a
comedy club yeah it took a minute just
it was definitely uh you know talking
into a microphone I've obviously done
that enough of my life but it was sort
of like not having lying necessarily
memorized that you do the whole episode
so they just keep giving you pages a
while so you do it like right there live
non-stem you just watching the cartoon
right oh no no no no you record first
and then they draw the card all that I
gotcha I gotcha uh yeah then how you do
the performance usually informs the
direction that the first draft of the
drawing goes uh you know it's it's a
hell of a process but I got to tell you
it was you know it was a lot of fun we
had a lot of fun and a lot of laughs and
we're hoping that people are gonna like
it no matter what I'm dumb this is the
most proud of any pilot or chunk of
episodes of anything that I've tried to
get on TV that I've ever made that I i
I'm really proud of this stuff that's
awesome so December eighteenth Netflix
and it bent watch all of them that's
great and then you just got a great
review d said today right who did that
one The Hollywood Reporter god it's
great that is great man I'm fired up for
it man it I love you man you're an
amazing human
I'm glad you're in my life thin and
thank you so much and you deserve
everything that you get man you're good
dude and and that's the bottom while
selling it to some of the people say
that the other people tell the truth but
i I've never met somebody say I'm never
a [ __ ] that guy I've never and I'm out
there all day and night it doesn't
happen yeah you know what they say the
best thanks Patti to circle a little bit
you can definitely fight let's not
exaggerate all right do you do how about
that oh thank god man thank god i love
you dude and anything else you want to
pump while you're wrong you got on the
road yeah you know what I'm actually
sitting near off Bonnie McFarlane has a
new book coming out you just sent it to
me open that I would uh itches I hey can
you just write a blurb about it or
something like that and uh this book I
like all and reread was like a chapter
two and just say it's funny but I'm
actually going to read the whole thing
it's hilarious why are we funny that's
cool what's it called you know what let
me see if I got the name of its not
summon out I don't know when it's coming
out I hang on I can't talk about it and
then not know the name hold on hold on
hold on it hang on dude I was just
watching a killer video you seen that
said from video where uh oh it's called
you're better than me okay you're better
than me um what's doing that drum video
where uh with dave grohl Questlove
Taylor Hawkins and all them are talking
about uh windows drumming and they're
sitting behind his iconic ludwig drum
kit no what's it weinberg who's that guy
aimed at that place with Paul McCartney
oh yeah but a a big or whatever what is
his name yeah he lives in B to a chad
smith all these killer drummers just
talking about Ringo's drumming and all
that and it's interesting my father's
just told me to watch it i just checked
it out but what's really cool about it
is the owner of the indianapolis colts
Jim Irsay just bought that get the 2.2
million dollars oh wow wow yeah all
those baby boomers man
yep you got something from their
childhood dude you can make a mint oh oh
god I i mean if i had cash it would just
be those led zeppelin sweat suits that
we look at honeybaked and then a Jimmy
project don't want so much money I want
to try to snag get to the point where I
know it's just ridiculous money and then
it's like all right I'm gonna get that
and then what I'm going to play like
John Bonham yes you look like some jerk
off and under root you know it's so true
because you you can't wear it you know
because it's worth the fortune and then
it's just in your house and people go
what's at Nia and first of all you got
to have people over to your house which
usually I don't want to show it I you
know what I mean all it does is remind
people that you're not that person did
you see Neil Peart retired yesterday
isn't it pure after all these years
you're supposed to say Neil pure or
something is yeah that actually
fascinated me because I don't you know I
bought like every drummer instructional
video ever I think just about all of
them and he had one from the late 90s
early 2000s where he was really working
on his technique which is hilarious
because he was already a drum god but he
went back to playing traditional Wow the
way we told in his dick you know like
Buddy Rich and all that it was really
all that let the stick through the work
and all that and I thought it was really
cool that a guy who was a draw thought
like his like him would stop and then go
all the way back to Ground Zero and
break it all down and remember on one
toward seeing that he was playing that
way it seemed and then the next tour he
went back to match grip he was just like
that's just like holding this fix the
way like a baby would grab on just like
the natural way you would grab cavemen
and and he retired saying that he had
that tendonitis in his forearms I was
wondering if it was actually from from
that drum hi [ __ ] it amazed me that
that was the reason why he was stopping
because i thought you know i watched
that video was like 20 years ago and it
this technique was incredible so I'm
surprised that he was I was I was up the
belief that if you learned you know that
moeller method technique with the sticks
doing the work and you're not you're all
relaxed how you end up getting that
stuff so I was kind of surprised by that
yeah I was surprised somebody just told
me cuz I'm thinking they only play like
once every five years why do you need to
retire you know you just kind of get
some like I know people that had
tendinitis they got surgery like some
kind of laser surgery or whatever and
they're back to normal you know must be
pretty in time I think also I mean the
guy he's in his 60s yeah he's he's
ridden a motorcycle over half the planet
he's done all of this type of stuff and
you know God knows he went through all
that unbelievable tragedy in the 90s and
stuff I just think you know maybe he's
like look I'm in the final third here
maybe I want to chill with my wife on my
kid I mean I think it's I like seeing
people i mean as a fan selfishly i'd
like to think you've gone but just you
know better performer watching somebody
watching them decide when it's over
rather than you have people going like
oh my god I saw rush in front of three
people at Circus Circus you know with
like 20 30 you know any what your course
would never have yeah I guess circus
circus haha but you know what I me
through believe me I fought to my wife
all the time about the exit strategy out
of this business and Joker's I'm like
they're not get me dude I'm not gonna be
that old comic in a tuxedo haha and in
there that's a maximum casino that still
exists in Vegas no going on right before
the a little the Lionel Richie
impersonator yeah i'm gonna try to the
lionel richie my money as wisely as you
can which is a very difficult thing to
do with all the criminals of it it's
crazy out there right I wanted to tell
you thanks for that pie I [ __ ] tore
that thing up and I had the worst
Thanksgiving ever moving my [ __ ] into
storage but that pie was the [ __ ]
gold gold key dude [ __ ] dude you should
have called me was just me and Nia
hanging out at the house would have
loved to have you over hey man I don't
actually ask she actually asked me she
goes what is being doing for
Thanksgiving I just assume you you were
probably hanging with Alice Cooper going
dude
good did I rather hang out with you than
any of the rock star so you know I never
get to see you anymore because you're
like [ __ ] so busy so any time to say
hey come over and I'm there man all
right absolutely well I gotta do the
parts for this thing and we got the
premiere next week I get you going to
that wednesday night at the arclight I
just got the invite i can't wait man
it's going to be incredible oh yeah it's
gonna be a good time you're going down
Rogan's going down and a buddy mine the
director my finder right did um I did a
film from a few years ago it is kids are
coming down they're all grown up to
coming down in that it's going to be
awesome time it's gonna be a great time
but after that food I'm on vacation oh
yes how long oh yeah I don't know yeah
why I gotta see in ordered really is I
don't haven't really have don't have
anything booked for next year could I
gotta see if we're going to get a second
season now thats place does it is they
they release it all at once and then
they you know now go to their secret
lair at the bottom of their building
evidently and then they decide like you
know if you're going to get a second
season so I've kind of left my tour
schedule open but I gotta tell you do
I'm so proud of this show that even if
we didn't get a second season like it
was still totally worth it to do it
because I had that much fun in the
amount of like cool creative people that
I met um you know it was just a it was
just a great experience but I gotta feel
I think we're gonna get I mean I never
talk trash but I mean I think people are
gonna like this god it's so cool what a
great era too i think i think it's my
favorite era of all time just the 70s i
love it man well even if you didn't come
up in the 70s you know this and it's
timeless enough words you know it's kids
rebelling against their parents I mean
it's we're not really reinventing the
wheel here so if you remember the 70s
that'll be cool but if you don't you can
still enjoy so there you go look at that
look at me being a politician over there
for everybody hi I love you dude and
I'll see you this week you're going to
be out at the clubs at all I gotta go to
New York to uh you know be a dancing
monkey here and promote this show only
come back next week
I'll be robbing down the store not just
weekend next weekend alright man thank
you so much and thank you for everything
we're at your studio and I love it here
thank you man I love you brother I'll
sucker you let see you later man see ya
bill burr man what sounds like he's
available for the februari improv versus
stand up with you the mean that's all I
heard oh that's all I heard it I heard
it was a headline in my 50th birthday I
[ __ ] love that man uh you guys are
real cute if you guys you know if he
wasn't married and you know you were
looking for love I could see a world
where that would work out man I just I
just love to be around somebody that's
completely their self in this business
you know what I mean that's so rare you
know there's a few guys have been lucky
enough to have as friends Marin and him
and and you know guys like that that uh
Joe Rogan you know that you're just like
that you can you can you know learn from
man it's just incredible and they're
great friends so yeah really cool and I
think this thing's get a smoke Kyle you
watch the trailer right it's great it's
fantastic yeah it is and I want some
other clips and it's just funny [ __ ] and
you know what you know it's gonna be
great you know my only only only fear
I'm gonna put it out there just let it
won't come true I don't think it's that
big of a deal but its star wars day oh
oh yeah premieres so yeah go watch Star
Wars and then come home and you know eat
some snacks and then watch every episode
of f is for a UH if it was on regular TV
I would say yeah that's a problem but
this is the netflix right that netflix
world and in that world people watch it
uh in line for ya so well they're bored
in line they go all right never and then
they're [ __ ] happy as hell laughing
at this [ __ ] line there in we gotta call
let's grab it hey man you're on the air
who's calling hey it's a Charlotte call
from the highway Sean from the highway
I've been there before yeah man I later
I tell you one day I'll look for my
rearview mirror and it was
you're just quoting lyrics from my
record four nights mentality now I'm
seeing things much clearer and I'm not
confused my god to did uh how are you
man well I got some memories that are
still remembered but you know some
broken hearts still remain Wow alright
was but one thing I can tell you Dean
and spicy is that she said the pain
never goes away I mean every rose has a
thorn yeah yeah yeah she's got the blue
chip Joe here's a man on the highway
roll inside ladies all alone what I
believe this actually on a November rain
wow you must have a slow day today like
I'm calling I just dude i love called
say hey man i love what you do it and i
want to congratulate you on your six
years okay thank you so much man where
you calling from men not call it from
you you're the jungle baby might be
connected down here right yeah yeah yeah
that is the jungle houston literally a
ballista swamp but i'm def shot so yeah
there are wide expanses of it that are a
little eerie yeah thank you so much man
and I thank you for the car tuning in
man so cool all right buddy I'm gonna
let you go thank you baby real buddy see
ya later spice so I saw some I wanted to
talk about the movies i saw this week oh
I got a chance to go to movies I was in
Vegas bored haha i saw creed you seen it
so you saw so good I've I'd you and you
were like no no I'm ago and it's like no
no I had a spot oh you were like no I'm
gonna be a loser and sit here and be and
I was like fine and that's not your I've
said I gotta do three spots right the
comedy store i'm home and underwear i
don't want to go out you left the story
then you came back and I was like did
you go yeah it's all right yeah it
wasn't that great so I mean it is the
formula yeah it is rocky one but updated
and modernized and done so i think i
told you this after i saw it like it's
the formula done well whereas in my
opinion southpaw the jake gyllenhaal
movie yeah is the same formula but
somehow a b-minus whereas Creed is an
a-plus it's like they just they know all
the beats they hit them
Michael B Jordan dude is a [ __ ] star
yep uh it just electric on the screen
every time you see him Sylvester
Stallone crushed it one of the best
acting performances I think he's ever
done it's unbelievable unbelievable I
think I cried like three times during
the film it's a choker man I've talked
to hey Zeus Trejo another comedian some
people might know and Nick Youssef after
I saw it and I man cried five times yeah
five times what man crying is there's
like real crying like tears and man
crying is also the like if anyone's
watching you can see i'll describe like
you're you're watching the movie and you
like you move around in your seat yeah i
mean you're like yeah and yours like
squirming lets me i'm crying that's
hemorrhoids yeah that's what you're it's
like this you're describing emotionally
uncomfortable but I don't know how to
handle it cuz I'm a man yeah it's like
yeah it's uh it gets you man well you
know what as I was watching the movie
and going back to bur show and stuff
like a grew up in the 70s and it really
hit me there on this film not all the
Rockies after you know it's like all the
jaws is after I don't care about but the
original the story and the character of
rocky you realize is so monumental in my
life as I saw that movie you know as a
kid you're like [ __ ] that as cheesy as
it sound makes you think like [ __ ] could
happen for me don't know when you're
just a loser kid and your mom you know
your own welfare and you got nothing you
know yet I've really really loved rocky
one and as I watched Creed it made me
love rocky one more yeah toto we got a
call I'm gonna look something up yeah
are you there man what's happening who's
calling its a bright here from its Frank
from first in Western Australia ok man
how are you I Australia love it dude
yeah not bad yourself yeah we're good
here we're just talking now we just got
off the air talking to bill burr about
his brand new show on Netflix Eva's for
family
I'm hoping that there's talk about
Netflix getting all the u.s. content
here so hopefully we'll be able to get
that as well yeah I say the moment we
have a city we have a limited netflix
content here at the moment but mostly
yeah we'll pick up all that stuff so
yeah yeah man once you do you're gonna
be not leaving the house you know cuz I
look at all the [ __ ] you can watch all
the great comedy specials and and all
the documentaries man you get sucked in
I all spent half my time sitting there
searching through everything trying to
decide what to watch i watch this line
should 02 / 02 Swan it's true right by
the time you pick something you fall
asleep how are you I that's what I
Rachel and I watching [ __ ] nothing so
how are you out in Australia yeah good
yeah awesome just heading off to work
and I noticed that I was just sitting
there having some breakfast before I
left and I saw you on periscope I
thought I'll give you a call then trying
to call for a wild at the times I never
really lied outside I thought this is a
perfect example if you can stir to give
you guys a buzz that's awesome man now
we're talking about anything today you
know do you have a question well I guess
I guess I 38 I am I got as you remember
or not I send you a recording of my son
oh I yield in your hood I do remember
that man whose son played guitar yeah
plays guitar seems a bit right to choose
songs and stuff and he's heading right
down the road of the acoustic side he's
played an electric his old life and he's
getting right into the acoustic stuff
than in the last couple of weeks we've
been really lucky here we've had done
some great bands too we had AC DC just
last week we had a couple of big aussie
bands the Living End and cold chisel to
trip and I went and saw both of them and
ac/dc as well and then he went and saw
edge here in the other night and it was
raving probably more about edge here and
than anybody else wow I was wondering
what
what you thought of it should because I
got it I mean I don't mind he's music
but it to me it sounds a little bit
older same but he said one man standing
on stage with no one else and and a
crowd of said he says he said was just
unbelievable Wow why I know it Sharon
just got nominated for a Grammy and I'm
a huge acoustic fan I mean I love Jeff
Tweety I love Wilco I love ryan adams i
love neil young guys when they play
alone and can hold a crowd is incredible
there's really nothing like that besides
comedy Jeff Buckley before we pass yes
well the best I've ever seen life Jeff
am a chair and guitar yeah [ __ ]
unbelievable I end and we're talking
about like rocky making us cry I seem
Tweety tell stories and go into songs
and just blow my [ __ ] mind you know
like wow yeah so i can relate yeah you
know if your son's loving instruments
and music that's just a win man oh yeah
I'm really I'm really proud of him eat
he works really knotted he spends a lot
of time practicing and / 14 year old t
to write songs and stuff and I really
you're baring your soul right yet so
it's not easy for a fourteen-year-old
specially 14 year old boy that was that
I can't let anybody know anything about
them but to sit there write songs and
it's pretty cool right yeah we try to
encourage you as much as we can well I
met I saw the video and this your kid
has killer talent man and usually when
people send me videos if their kids or
whatever I'm I'm like ah you know it's
like cuz of course you feel parent
you're like look how great my kid is
he's totally talented then you go yeah
but your kid had up man I and I wrote
you back and I told you I said man that
guy has it yeah oh yeah I appreciate
that are just interested in your in your
own in your thoughts which obviously
been around musical long time you've
seen some of the greats and it's always
nice teddy because you know we're
friends eli where you go on talent
you got there but it's not to get
somebody's opinion who actually knows
what the [ __ ] they're talking about
rather than to say Mississippi not yeah
we'll keep him on the track on visual
keep him on the track yeah he's got a
few more songs actually ready to go and
just go to find time to get him in the
studio and getting recorded so that's
great that's all day doesn't lyrics
himself out all the guitar himself the
last one that was it but this next one
he wants to do the base as well so
that's awesome tell everyone before you
go tell everyone where they can see that
it's on YouTube right I know it's not on
YouTube but it's on he's on itunes and
you can see it on a private on Apple
music as well he's named Scooter Braun
so get out there and have a listening to
it awesome support support young talent
absolutely man thanks for calling in i
love you and i hope to get to australia
soon man if i do you're on the list oh
man don't worry almost happy to find my
wife i will say to say up with my green
beans should think turns up i'll take it
down to ponce that you'll get a photo of
it with him god I can't wait can't wait
to get there man Australia is common
well the toes on May night so i'll give
you the tour of Fremantle and the full
ac/dc experience there you go man
candles lit thanks for calling in okay
got a good one see ya later so what I
was gonna say what I looked up to get
the facts right before I messed it up no
spoilers here not that is it's not as
hard to spoil creed um no spoilers but
in the movie Creed in his first
professional fight yeah there is a scene
and there is a fight and it is two
rounds and that is all one take oh yeah
I read one take they shot at 12 times in
the 10th time was the one they used in
the film and this is too real rounds of
boxing yeah choreographed where they
have the fighters moving around the
Apple in the corners reacting the
audience reacting yeah and then you have
a person with a Steadicam in the ring
maneuvering around this thing I remember
watching it going this is incredible it
looks like one take but after Birdman
came out yeah you just assume that it's
creative trickery or whatever like oh
the referee crossed the film after they
cut it right yeah no one [ __ ] tape ah
incredible so it's a beautiful movie
just to watch and enjoy and love and
also technically and what I also wanted
while there is a a plot point about a
gun in Creed there's no guns no there's
no guns there's no like so much there's
violence is boxing but like so much of
today's world is horrific at times and
it's nice to go watch a movie that is
deep complex mature and doesn't reduce
itself to spraying the world with
explosions yeah yeah well it's a story
right I think they the thing about Rocky
one was it wasn't a boxing movie it was
a love story right it was just a love
for a city a love for a sport and a love
of a woman that he meets in a pet store
yeah that [ __ ] blows my mind those
scenes are so tender against the violent
boxing right that it's really
mind-boggling the juxtapose of it when
you watch it you skill like wow yeah and
and the way that film looked you know
everything about it and and it's funny
here we are a hundred years later and
the character still feels great to me
yeah you know and he really you know cuz
there's so many of those Rocky's that
happen later is just a google one rocky
one rocky 2 and then Rocky Balboa yeah
and then Creed yeah to me that's the
rocky narrative the others are funny
yeah after you've watched those for the
art then go watch rocky against Mike in
the street fighter whatever the [ __ ]
rocky five or whatever that was rocky
one rocky to Rocky Balboa Creed yeah
great movies I mean you know you gotta
look at that area rocky you had jaws he
got Cuckoo's Nest all these films that
had incredible characters and incredible
acting Stallone can [ __ ] act yeah and
it was funny I was talking to somebody I
can't we're all it was Ian Edwards and
he was like man I so tired all those
comedians when they just four years
would do stolen lululu and then you
realize yeah that's a character he's
done just like this rocky one man he's
[ __ ] great in it you know and he was
great in Copland and
no one ever talks about that cop land
was going to be like his comeback
because the copland was a shitty movie I
liked kalo that's like three and a half
hour it's bloated Oscar bait is what it
is I look I think he's good in it but it
is like we're trying to make this
serious movie about these hot button
issues and I was just like oh now I tell
you what I'm [ __ ] going crazy over
look I mean crazy is this Leonardo film
coming out I have friends that have seen
it and while I cannot say what my
friends have told me I can't say which
friends have told me they loved it they
loved it oh I mean first of all it's
funny because I want i was in the
theater and they showed the trailer for
the hateful eight yo now which I've
heard is also [ __ ] almost perfect
really yeah well the trailers not the
trailer makes it just look like this
kind of hokey LaQuinton the new queen
yeah yeah like a Hokies you know like a
Saturday Night Live sketch or something
it's just joke after joke after joke
every year like I get it you're just
like it was just punch lines there's no
and it's funny because I talked to
somebody that saw the film and they go
yeah the trailer is not the tone of the
movie at all and I think maybe they're
trying to make it feel a little light so
you get in there and then you just seem
mad and killing us you know yeah but
they showed that trailer and and and
Tarantino is such a stylistic man yeah
all his films look incredible they have
a very heavy style feel like a Wes
Anderson movie know it's a Tarantino
film but I watched that and it didn't
feel like anything and right after that
trailer came the Leonardo fell revenant
or something like that revenue yeah oh
[ __ ] when you see the way the sweeper
shot on the [ __ ] Lake and then the
snow and then horse going over the cliff
and and the bear and everything you're
just going like what this thing looks
unbelievable and it's the Birdman
director yeah but if I may cross promote
another all things comedy podcast a
dollop they did an amazing episode about
this okay look back in the archives it's
about a movie about the story of Hugh
glass oh wow the real guy yeah the real
guy it's a true story right yeah but yet
it's amazing
Birdman director and also another
technical marvel that may or may not pay
off come award season all natural light
Wow and so here's a guy who's known for
his huge sweeping crane I've seen the
magnificent hands in the beautiful
cinematography all natural light and so
they got kept getting [ __ ] on on
budget in time because yeah whether you
want to say its climate change or
whatever about poor planning little a
little be like they were shooting and
the weather wasn't cooperating so they
had to leave they were shooting scenes
when it was supposed to be the winter
when it was spring and getting hot and
are out there on furs and they're out
there was supposed to be spring and it
was like negative 14 oh and the cast and
crew is just [ __ ] suffering oh but it
looks like visually it pays off I've
heard the story is fairly simple like
it's not there's not like we know a
Shyamalan twist right it's a guy going
to avenge a son well that's all brave
heart is I guess great they're out like
on some kind of expedition and then a
Barrett aksam and then they leave him
for dead right and then they kill his
son for some reason we don't know yet
but he sees his son getting killed yeah
as he's like buried still kind of alive
or whatever uh Tom Harding yeah who's
[ __ ] great and I and I can't say it
enough but I think Leonardo is so
underrated man I mean from Gilbert Grape
all the way on I've always been
entertained by this man I don't know if
he's underrated I would like to see not
rated then I think he is I mean he
hasn't won an Oscar I'd like to see him
bring a statue home but I don't think
there's anyone that are like that that
honestly thinks he can't act I think
maybe it's Playboy life's but they never
talk about it you know I be like I
thought he was incredible in the in the
aviator man you know and gilbert grape
and of course everything he does i think
i wonder if it's because he's such a
wonderful person and like everybody
envies him yeah that people don't talk
about him and hold him up because it's
kind of like Tom Brady the quarterback
of the New England Patriot yeah here's a
beautiful man who has a beautiful wife
beautiful children a beautiful football
everything's going good so no one needs
to sing his praises because he's [ __ ]
Tom Brady versus someone like oh god
what's his name
Lincoln incredible like Daniel day-lewis
do day-lewis incredible [ __ ] actor
yeah but like for all we know doesn't
have the charmed life of being perfect
like instead he goes out and lives in
the woods for two months to prepare for
a role so it's easy to lift him up or
like John Malkovich yeah there's like
Weiner DiCaprio incredible [ __ ] actor
but we were not watching his movies are
watching him [ __ ] ten supermodels yeah
so no one is like dude I mean I'm going
back I've been watching this [ __ ] guy
since I was a kid yeah Gilbert Grape
Basketball Diaries he'll like never I
mean he was in basketball diaries that
he looking great film you know so it's
uh I can't wait for that and as I watch
the trailers like just give him all the
awards it looks good oh man it looks
great yeah now I saw bong did you see
bond I haven't seen it I've heard it was
interesting but forgettable you know
it's [ __ ] weird is everybody said
that and it almost detoured me from
seeing it but I'm a huge bond guy and Mr
Bond since Roger Moore eres pile of me
was the first one I ever saw as a kid
and I was like oh I thought I'd hooked
and I've seen everyone uh and I tell you
what this [ __ ] films great I think
the people are just like I think you
just want like non-stop something you
know this film had all it had bond skin
which we always need bond or bond in the
snow not necessarily skiing but snow
bond right it had trained bond it's on a
train it had car chase bond that's
december i mean that's january bond
getting the calendar yeah yeah but all
the classic bond [ __ ] it had amazing um
uh locations were blowing my mind yeah
and and [ __ ] the the new bond is just
killer man yeah you know that guy
crushes it is this Daniel Craig's last
Bond it's rumored it might be his life I
just said that cuz they asked him
immediately after he finished yeah I got
so hurt on this one he's like never but
oh yeah I think he's hoping yeah yeah
and he's wearing a great watch in this
manner watchdog me Omega hit it out of
the park with this new Bond watch 7,500
bucks Omega bond model and I've
immediately has like I nude
haha so cool man but go out and see bond
man I can I don't understand why people
making sure it was my list we're
slagging on that man it's freaking
really good me hey soos and Jeremiah saw
it in Vegas all three of us walked out
like that was [ __ ] great and we
sought for phi dollars which was unheard
of in LA so right five bucks it was just
smoking for five bucks no I think a lot
of things in Vegas are cheap because
everything else isn't yeah so like
anything other than like it seemed like
yeah okay you need a break here we'll
pay you to go see this yeah and now go
gamble yeah go [ __ ] [ __ ] we don't
waste your life it is we have it on my
list oh god it's really good what else
is on your list so this is called having
a seven-month-old oh yes haven't the
every time a movie comes out I want to
see add it to my list so here's what I
haven't seen that I still want daddy
because I don't add it to a list i
forget about it yeah you just get hyped
up about the new things it's true inside
out ant-man Mission Impossible rogue
nation the gift sicario Saqqara saw the
Steve Jobs inspector I didn't see that
mission impossible which is which is
weird cuz i love that series too it was
really good [ __ ] i forgot all about that
move that's why I hope that's why I'm
checking and I'm gonna add revenant to
it right now was only talked about right
before revenant uh oh hey Polly hey
valet there's a lot of great movies
coming out god so many a lot of great
ones uh you know we got the Tarantino
hateful eight we have this this one we
have Star Wars Star horse I mean it
seems like it's going to be a really oh
and uh crowded Christmas what's that
it's brad pitt and that looks great too
sure the big short oh like that that
[ __ ] looks great and Brad Pitt that's
about the banks being robbers yeah it
looks good man like so creating it not
to bring the conversation down a bit but
I had somebody's talking about this and
it's scary and it's weird and whatever
after San Bernardino the mass shooting
in terrorist act we got one here in
Southern California people were talking
I had friends groups of friends of mine
sitting around going hey are you still
going to go to Star Wars opening day
yeah and they're like you know what I
think so i think that there's a
you know we're in a big enough city that
the chance at the theater that I see it
in it and there's a mass shooting their
small right like statistically it's
small for everybody but one we have
lived in a privileged society where we
don't have to think about this [ __ ]
there are people in countries all over
the world where they have to deal with
real-life violence every day yeah
they're not even go into a movie theater
they don't have movie yeah but it's
interesting it was the first time in my
adult life we're not as a joke or
whatever it was a serious conversation
we're friends were like are you guys
still going to go to this right or does
this concern you and that's [ __ ] up um
that is I don't I need to dive into my
field beliefs on guns like it was just
weird talking about movies and
light-hearted and you know going and
watching things it's uh you know it's
interesting yeah I mean you know uh
being around the rodeo people that I was
talking about earlier yeah with burr
it's a it's funny because I was sitting
in the casino and these guys everyone
I'm talking [ __ ] thousands yeah i'm
not i'm talking about one of the biggest
rodeos in the world is comes to vegas
and it is like something you've never
seen yeah and I appreciate at first i'm
clownin them because they're wearing
these cowboy hats at these [ __ ] every
guy the same cowboy hat big belt silver
belt with gold letters like champion
aware than boots and and the [ __ ]
Wranglers you know yeah i'm clownin them
and then I'm think I yeah then look how
I dress you know it's still trying to be
a rock and roll 50 which is my look it's
in my blood I could never just all the
sudden start wearing cotton Dockers and
a button-up shirt ionno button up shirts
no tie I don't know how to add a [ __ ]
tired i had no Blazers none of that [ __ ]
so I'm clowning on them but it is
amazing when you think about how
different people are from the states man
you know like I'm John California New
York Portland Seattle Austin part of
Texas awesome yeah yeah and that's
probably in maybe colouring over
there are some other areas Madison
Wisconsin like a weird couple sprinkles
but the rest really really feels to me
like they live in the like 40 still or
something I don't know what it is it's
just uh they're really rigid uh-huh on
any like thing you know gay gay marriage
guns races everything it's it's pretty
strange and it's scary because as I
watched that I was like well this is
your Trump's talking to yeah you're
seeing it changed though and I think in
Maryland WTF episode with Lauren
Michaels you know Lauren has an
interesting perspective on that as well
he's like you know that New York and LA
press was killing us like this is when
Mark was auditioning and just like
dragons over the coals and he's like but
we realized you know that's not who were
playing to that's who's riding up
reviews about us saying were dead but
we're killing in nebrask that was
amazing he said that to me yeah not to
me too he said that and I heard and I
was like wow he said that's not our
market right which is really crazy
because as I watched the jokes it feels
like it is trying to be that market and
it's just not edgy enough for that
market right and that but straight up
said you know that's not what we're
going for but now you know you have
shows like SNL and stuff like that
unites a culture to some extent and now
with like Netflix everybody's going to
go watch Bill show on the eighteenth and
it's like here's someone that otherwise
we wouldn't had access to a spike in
Mike's animation festival when it was in
San Francisco and I see like edgy
awesome [ __ ] and everybody gets to see
everything and culture is being
homogenized which can be looked at as a
negative i was joking with you when we
were in phoenix like oh man what do you
do in what do you do in Scottsdale the
same thing you do everywhere watch
Netflix and go to chilis flag America
everywhere yeah at the same time you
know culture and beliefs and views are
being shared into pockets of the world
where they had never met an Indian
before and now everybody's watching is
he's in saris master of none and they're
getting that perspective whether you
agree with in our clapping along it
doesn't matter you're seeing something
that in your town you know in my suburb
of Houston there were like four black
kids yeah that's crazy yeah so I don't
know I
it's good to be exposed to stuff I did
say that's where we're going as a
society that's why I never knock it
stirs because I think whenever I go to a
town I go where do the hipsters hang out
cuz that's going to be where the good
shits going to be some good food a
record store some multicultural you know
there's going to be it's going to be
different races and you know so it's
it's just crazy you know it all it's
funny this whole episode has a great
theme around f is for family you know as
it comes down to back in an era where
everybody was just like really kind of
their self they weren't really pushing
stuff down and hiding stuff yeah you
know whatever they were if they you know
it was out in the open the only the only
difference to that and me being a little
younger than you so maybe have changed
the difference I feel like where we are
now is everything is out in the open in
terms of like snapchat Twitter Facebook
like celebrities don't have private
lives whereas before maybes in the 50s
or 60s when you went home and close the
door yeah that [ __ ] was off-limits to
anyone else like if you were in your
house and you heard your neighbor
beating the [ __ ] out of their kid or
wife or their husband or a periscope in
it right and you weren't knocking on
their door calling the cops like that
was like they're in their gig that's
their [ __ ] now it's you know if I see a
kid at the park and like a parent is ten
feet away I'm like oh I should probably
call Child Protective Services they
should be five feet oh you know what I
mean like that's a ludicrous example but
there wasn't an era where you shut your
door and you were done we got a call
let's grab it hey man you're on the air
who's calling hey this is the eric from
Michigan what's going on man we're part
of michigan in detroit [ __ ] yeah Detroit
I love Detroit they will park after this
yeah this is Dean Del Rey let there be
talk oh no [ __ ] you know I so [ __ ] you
stand up funniest look I never listen to
podcast before I thought this was
puncher run hey buddy yeah that's a
couple hours ago haha noon to two every
Tuesday yeah so but now you listen to
Dean's podcast cuz you're on it
I can tell your friends like myth is
when I called the wrong podcast check it
out it had one hour and 10 second chair
what are you guys talking about we're
talking about anything you want to talk
about what's going on in Detroit you
live out there what do you do out there
for a job right now I'm [ __ ] driving
auto parts around and saw him smoking
weed smoking weed now oh no big-time no
I would be bad haha now now Detroit I
when I watched a thing on youtube I
don't know if you saw it but it was
johnny Knoxville he did a 30 minute
documentary on Detroit with like
hipsters are fixing it up and urban
farming and all that are you are you
part of that at all or do you see that
party on Troy there's a lot of hipsters
down there now it's like there's it's
basically just like I'm in there still
park that you don't want to go to but
there's a lot of Detroit that's just all
hipsters and it's hitting revitalized
that's cool right yeah that's definitely
cool they're doing them but yeah they're
doing a bunch of urban farming too I saw
that because it's incredible yeah now
have you ever been out to that area
where Jack White used to live we're all
the automotive billionaires you still
having those giant like mansions yeah
like girls point yeah gross point yeah
I've been there I go there every day I'm
delivering auto parts oh [ __ ] let me ask
you something cuz i'm i'm curious what
is what is do you live alone do you have
a roommate what is the average rent in
detroit should I live alone right now I
live 20 minutes outside the city
probably 20-25 my rents 550 a month for
a single bedroom and what kind is it's
like a one-bedroom apartment or what is
it yeah it's a one-bedroom apartment
it's it's two separate rooms and it's
like 750 square feet why
out 550 you know what that cost in LA
2000mah yeah that's [ __ ] insane hi
unless you want to live in like complete
heroin gunfire area and their dirty 1800
yeah yeah the city said 50 Dodgers early
now do you enjoy Detroit yeah it's but I
though I actually want to [ __ ] moves
up to some other city marikina I
actually do a little bit of stand-up
comedy on the side that's awesome man
that's awesome dead I'm never gonna let
you open fight and but this is not much
but seeing out here now do they really
there's no like comedy scene in Detroit
like in the hipster air like open mics
and alt shows and stuff there's Bobby
there's a lot of all shows like bad wat
like music wise right but uh so much
comedy there's like there's two or three
good clubs out here that's out in the
comedy castle yeah mark Ridley's was out
here yeah in a row that's uh that's a
pretty decent one what's it all the more
Vanya yeah there's a cup there's a
couple work release is pressed well I
mean it sounds like Detroit is like
where you should maybe start your own
show you know get it [ __ ] gone
because your rent is low and I mean and
and you to be an artist you got to have
a low overhead so maybe start your own
show up dude find a place and do it yeah
actually yeah I need to get a stronger
act together first well it doesn't know
what you do is you start your own show
do an open mic and then you host it and
you become a [ __ ] great comedian from
being on stage non-stop hosting it you
know yeah huh try it did and then book
Dean and ein will come out now and you
know be fun well if I can support your
show did so go out and do it and call in
a few months and tell me how it's going
and this show is found like 230 to 330
Pacific that Pacific what it's what was
it called over time let there be talk
it's on iTunes Dean Del Rey's letter B
talk okay yeah dude and watch bill
burr's new TV show December eighteenth f
is for family all right yeah I felt the
trailer looks delish I [ __ ] missed
bill burr when he was in Detroit I was
so pissed oh yeah he was just there man
yeah I know I was pissed god I wish I
would have seen that but yeah go start
that open mic did you can do it man
don't [ __ ] be lazy put down the pipe
and hit it yeah right thank you guys you
gotta do it see you later man we gotta
go I take care of anything later that's
the show man let's think bill burr for
calling in what a what a great guy and
everybody wants to get wat to show yeah
what do you got coming spice this
thursday is improv vs stand up here at
UCB LA it used to be Franklin if you are
in Los Angeles also want to give a shout
out to cynic cave in San Francisco it's
at last week in video it's every
saturday i was just up there last
saturday it is one of my favorite shows
on earth oh yeah ball shin basement and
just incredible show NATO Green Dragon
what did you drop my name and oh and
Dean Del Rey I wasn't on the step plug I
gotta plug Dean Del Rey let me see what
else uh and also Dean Del Rey if you
don't follow Dean go right get out if
you followed in delray ah alright real
quick gonna be a death squad Secret Show
Wednesday night very very big guest
headliner me red band and a few other
great comedians 830 in the main room
friday night i'll be at the comedy store
in the main room 11 p.m. i'll be at the
Laugh Factory 1230 Sunday night and then
i'm off to not sunday night friday night
sunday night to see lemmy's birthday
party going to lemmy's party and I'll
periscope from there and show you guys a
little lemy 70th birthday thanks for
calling in everyone keep leaving the
reviews and if you want to donate hit
patreon.com / Dean
el rey to this podcast very easy way to
to donate spicer set it up and I'm at
155 bucks i think which is awesome
that's awesome that is killer man so
thanks everybody and keep rockin see ya
light the candles yeah you gotta hit
that [ __ ] hit that [ __ ] hit that [ __ ]
hit that [ __ ] hit that [ __ ]
hit that [ __ ]